remakes and remasters are still
happening a whole lot in 2016 and it's a
really good opportunity to get back into
a game you used to love or try one out
that you may have missed here are some
cool ones throughout this year if you've
already played heavy rain then you might
feel like I do in that I loved it but
I'm happy with how my playthrough went
down and I don't really need to play it
again
that said it is a really great game that
you should play if you haven't already
Quantic Dream also recently remastered
beyond two souls but given its clumsy
narrative and unbalanced difficulty the
less said about that game the better
heavy rain on the other hand is a breed
be working with time QuickTime events
and/or Quantic Dream beefed up beyond
two souls with quote enhanced 1080p
graphics so presumably we can expect a
similar treatment for heavy rain if
you're in the mood to have the worst
time ever as Ethan was repeatedly shout
Jason make a billion life threatening
decisions and uncover the mystery of the
origami killer this one's for you
in general the Legend of Zelda remasters
have been really well made and received
so hopefully twilight princess HD
follows the trend originally launching
on GameCube and Wii the remaster has
been developed at Ozzy studio Tantalus
and will make its way onto Wii U come
March for Twilight Princess HD will
feature updated graphics and amiibo
support the brand-new wolf link amiibo
is set to unlock the cave of shadow area
in game while the link term link
Ganondorf Princess Zelda and Sheik
amiibo will all provide various buffs
and debuffs to link in Twilight Princess
HD for example your little plastic Zelda
will restore hearts while Ganondorf
makes link take more damage the retail
version of the game will also come
packaged with the wolf link and Midna
amiibo so you can either begin or add to
your collection of mostly useless little
figurines adventure game fans rejoice
the golden era of classic
point-and-click games may be behind us
but thanks to remasters you can still
live the brain twisting puzzles enter
day of the tentacle remastered day of
the tentacle remastered is a cult
favorite thanks to its sense of humor
and multiple protagonists who lets you
interact with the world in a bunch of
different ways it's set to arrive on the
Vita of ps4 PC Mac and Linux in March of
this year Tim Schafer confirmed the fan
favorite game will still be in its 2d
cartoon art style but the resolution
will be increased for modern computers
you'll also be able to switch on
commentary and play the original maniac
mansion within the remaster of cherry on
top though has to be that a
full-throttle remaster is also drew out
later this year which remains my
absolute favorite LucasArts adventure
game if you live in the west you could
be forgiven for not knowing that the
remakes of Dragon Quest 7 and Dragon
Quest 8 the journey of the curse of King
are both out in Japan luckily for us
though arguably the best games in the
crazy long-running and Japanese
chart-topping Dragon Quest franchise are
officially on their way to the Western
market where some big JRPG franchises
have branched out and tried new things
the Dragon Quest series has always stuck
to its hardcore fantasy RPG roots
keeping its old-school turn-based battle
system and random encounters while
telling massively grand stories first
Dragon Quest 7 & 8 are slated to arrive
on 3ds this year and Dragon Quest 8 is
already available as support on mobile
devices worldwide the news was unveiled
during November's Nintendo Direct
finally wildly popular platformer
Ratchet & Clank is coming back to the
spotlight after 14 years insomniac games
are calling the game a reimagining of
the first game in the series and it will
also be based on and launching alongside
the upcoming Ratchet and Clank film it's
landing on the ps4 come April 12 in
North America and a few days later for
Europe the remake will include a variety
of gameplay elements from different
entries in the series and brand new
weapons for you to try your hand at
including one that zaps foes into eight
bits
of themselves let me know what remake a
remaster or re-release you're excited to
play this year down in that comment
section or you can chat to me on my
Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald and I
will see you again soon